Pour aider les hommes à se dégager du bocage,
Bradley a prévu d'écraser
d'abord sous les bombes,
les positions allemandes
sur la ligne de front
qui sépare les 2 ennemis.
La percée une fois effectuée,
ces troupes s'élanceront simultanément
vers la Bretagne ainsi,
que vers la Seine et la Loire.
Le 25 juillet, l'aviation alliée attaque
la route entre Saint Lô et Perrier,
où les 2 armées sont au contact.
La fameuse division blindée du général Leyer,
le second du maréchal Rommel,
est anéantie sous les bombes.
À partir de ce périmètre d'enfer,
les hommes peuvent enfin sortir du bocage.
Ils créent cette brèche dans
le front ennemi si longtemps attendu.
En plus la pêche est bonne
à voir tous ceux qui se rendent.
Même si parfois,
elle ramasse quelques menus fretin.
Dans ce bestiaire
qu'est devenu la Normandie,
les chars sont désormais équipés
de lames pour cisailler les haies,
franchir les derniers kilomètres de bocage.
Avant même la fin juillet,
la percée réussie,
les blindés américains atteignent
Coutances, Avranches et Granville,
derniers ports normands avant la Bretagne.
Début août, la 2ᵉ division blindée française,
débarque à son tour à Utah Beach.
Depuis des mois, des années,
ces Français avaient tout quitté
pour combattre les Allemands
et les Italiens en Afrique,
tandis qu'ils s'apprêtent
cette fois en vainqueurs,
à fouler à nouveau leur cher sol de France.
À leur tête, le général Leclerc,
sec comme sa canne,
mais aussi valeureux que droit.
Tout aurait dû porter
cet aristocrate du côté de Vichy,
mais il a choisi de suivre
de Gaulle, dès juin 40.
Maintenant,
c'est en libérateur qu'il débarque.
Sa division est intégrée
à la 3ᵉ armée américaine,
avec laquelle elle va pouvoir participer
aux opérations sur le sol national.
Quartier général de Bradley.
Sous les objectifs du cinéaste
américain George Stevens,
Montgomery, jamais insensible aux caméras
décors quelques soldats yankee.
Il sait bien faire.
Poussé par Eisenhower,
l'Anglais a accepté de laisser la direction
de la bataille finale aux Américains.
Pour la mener à bien, Bradley
compte aussi sur un certain général Patton.
L'homme au pistolet à la crosse
d'ivoire est un fonceur.
"Au premier pet de travers, on s'attend
à ce que je les sorte de leur m***",
a-t-il coutume de dire.
Au petit matin, les Allemands tentent
une opération de la dernière chance.
Depuis la plaine de Caen, il lance
une contre-attaque à Mortain,
espérant rejeter les alliés à la mer.
L'offensive planifiée par H**** en personne,
est aussitôt enrayée par les typhus,
des lance-roquettes des alliés.
"Cette affaire n'avait
aucune chance de succès",
écrira Van Klug avant de se s****.
Elle aura été la dernière
offensive allemande.
Pire encore à Mortain,
Bradley a laissé volontairement
l'ennemi s'enfoncer dans le flanc allié.
Désormais, les Allemands sont coincés
entre les Américains au sud,
et les Britanniques au nord.
Bradley va pouvoir effectuer la manœuvre
à laquelle il pense depuis longtemps :
Prendre l'ennemi en tenaille entre
les divisions britanniques venues
de la plaine de Caen,
et les armées américaines plus au sud.
Avant que les deux mâchoires de son piège
se referme entre Argentan et Falaise,
sur une Wehrmacht en retraite.
Sitôt la contre-offensive
allemande stoppée à Mortain,
Patton et ses divisions se sont élancées
vers Le Mans en direction de Paris.
Maintenant, une partie d'entre elles,
bifurque vers Argentan,
entreprennent le large mouvement de feu
qui encercle les Allemands.
Tandis qu'au nord, les Anglo-canadiens
opèrent la jonction entre alliés.
La Wehrmacht a été laminée,
et Eisenhower pourra écrire,
" Le champ de bataille de Falaise fut
sans conteste l'un des plus grands champs
de tuerie qu'aucun secteur
de la guerre n'eut jamais connu".
C'était un spectacle que seul
la plume d'un Dante eût pu décrire.
On pouvait avancer sur des centaines
de mètres sans interruption,
en ne marchant littéralement
que sur des chairs mortes et pourrissantes.
5 à 6 000 morts du côté allemand.
À voir la tête de ceux qui ont été capturés,
on sent qu'il n'a pas exagéré.
Il faudra plusieurs jours pour évacuer
les 30 à 40 000 prisonniers de falaise.
Pour eux, la captivité est une victoire,
celle de la vie sur la m****.
La Wehrmacht a mobilisé de nombreux
hommes dans les pays qu'elle occupe.
Tous n'ont pas eu à cœur de défendre
leur Reich jusqu'au trépas.
Cette fois, c'en est fini
de l'Allemagne en Normandie.
Falaise terminer et ces prisonniers évacués,
les armées de Patton ont franchi
la Seine et la Loire.
Dès lors, Eisenhower a atteint les 2
limites fixées par le plan Overlord.
Il désire passer maintenant
à l'étape suivante :
La poussée vers le Reich.